Honeybees learn math.
How smart can honeybees be?
Honeybees have proven to be surprisingly intelligent...
...compared to other critters in the insect kingdom.
They have their own dance communication system and can understand the concept of zero.
And the recent study shows that that's not all they can do.
New research published in the journal Science Advances...
...reveals that honeybees are capable of understanding simple math problems.
The Australian research team began by teaching 14 honeybees...
...the basic rules of arithmetic.
They trained them to enter a y-shaped maze...
...where they first faced a series of color geometric shapes.
The number and the color of the shapes would vary.
If the shapes were blue,...
...the bee had to add one unit to the image presented at the entrance.
If the shapes were yellow, it had to subtract one unit.
If they chose the correct answer they would be rewarded with sugar water.
If the answer was incorrect, they would get a bitter solution called quinine.
After 100 trials that took four to seven hours,...
...the bees had learned a basic concept of addition and subtraction.
The bees were able to choose the correct answer between 63 and 72 percent of the time.
Not too bad for a sesame-sized brain.
Of course, this is extremely simple stuff...
...but it is quite impressive that an insect with a brain that measures a cubic millimeter...
...can figure out basic math in 100 tries.